l'estonie à paris 1
il ya eu beaucoup de déchet bones aussi
ouais c était défoncée son feu mais je
crois que oui j'aime beaucoup jouer
pareil parce que tu fous c'est différent
c'est un problème parce que il ya les
problèmes avec ne l'appelez sur les
politiques eux mais ça fait quoi qu'on
ait connu fait un spectacle et c'est la
dernière fois c'est pas ma vraiment mais
elle et les gens qui ont su livrer tous
les politiques et tout ça mais c'est un
johnny tu trouves que le public français
très violent mais le street fighting man
pour nous est une sorte d'appel au
meurtre ou à la violence et pour les
anglais ils écoutent ça très calmement
oui c'est vrai c'est une chance pour les
anglais au sujet de la violence dans les
rues vous souvenez tous levés en senior
est ce que tu te sens une responsabilité
vis-à-vis des jeunes quand tu viens dans
un pays responsable et fait oui pour les
français comme ça c'est très difficile
cochrane qu'on est les tul à l'étranger
chose ne pas consulter vraiment c'est
impossible pour moi de de faire notre
petit pour quelqu'un qui est qu'elle
dont une part il peut rien faire pour
les gens qui sont à mes yeux pas les
aider tu es un symbole pour toute une
jeunesse c'est à dire que mick jagger
avec les rolling stones c'est ce que
tous les types qui sont autour de toi
voudrais m non c'est parfois vous êtes
un secret
non je n'aime pas les légendes les simba
et ses seins vraiment mais sympa faire
la différence mais je n'aime pas qu'est
ce que ça vous a fait pour vous
haletante le fait qu'il ya un type de
tuer non dans ce festival on vous étiez
sur scène à ce moment là ce que vous en
êtes aperçu non j'avais vu dans le film
mais pas de pain c'est très citoyen à
côté là de lacoste qu'on dit que ce
serait les aloses la scène alors mais il
n'y a pas de lumière seulement l'air les
fonds ne pas l'aimer parce qu'elle est
le soir je n'ai jamais vu et dont le
film je veux beaucoup de d'estève ans
partent beaucoup t il ya tout le temps
comme ça mais juge qu est-ce qui avait
demandé aux aux hells angels de faire le
service de sécurité
mais j'ai quand même parce que là je
veux pas je ne suis pas une fin mais il
arrive à la vie c'est pas moi qui vais à
quelques mois je ne je suis par le
producteur de ses spectacles vraiment ce
soit les chante depuis toujours arriver
à contrôler non je le contrôle jamais si
tu penses que l'on peut contrôler si
face tu joues si je ne peux pas j'ai pas
mal rires dans la salle ne pense pas que
je pense que je suis encore en contrôler
le feu oui c'est pareil c'est impossible
parce que je chante à 20 personnes âgées
les personnes
elle s'est vu souffler ne sais pas si tu
ne veux pas
c'est la seule chose et c'est de faire
une chose mais je n'ai pas confiance en
avril est qu'une chose c'est rosina en
obligeant leur tour les gens bricolent
français quelqu'un qui arrive un
spectacle il ne veut pas contrôler et il
veut et je veux les gens qui concerne
les foules et sert à rien leur dire de
ce contrôle
ils sont pas venus pour ça c'est pour ça
qu'on peut ils ne veulent pas avec ta
musique
et si tu veux simplement de rendre les
gens heureux ou et situ de changer leurs
esprits mais je ne tiens pas changé
l'esprit de quiconque il faut être fou
pour changer la vie des gens contrôler
leur commun avec les stones comment veux
tu changé lundi reviews sans changer le
monde avant on doit être responsable de
soi même et quand on arrive à un stade
où on a suffisamment confiance en soi on
découvre que l'on peut aussi faire
confiance à d'autres gens john lennon
dans aucune classe et audi justement le
contraire c'est que je ne pense pas
comme lui je n'aime pas c'est une autre
que je préfère c'est juste deux à trois
mois
[Musique]
les banques l'abe sont là mais qu'est ce
que tu connais personnellement john
lennon oui mais ce n'est pas vraiment
mon ami
[Musique]